التقطت كاميرات Mndot هذا الأسبوع
أكثر من 1500 شريحة
زلة وتحطم ثلجي ، وربما لا أحد
يشاهد شاحنة القمامة تلك الكاميرات
خارج نطاق السيطرة تمامًا مثل أليكس
سميث
الذي حوّل جزءًا من منزله الجديد في برايتون
إلى غرفة مخصصة لتتبع
اكتشف النظام ما لا يقل عن 655 حادثًا في
تفاصيل حطام الطرق في أكثر من ذلك ،
إنها وظيفة بدوام جزئي إنها مشروع شغوف
ولكن في أسبوع مثل اليوم ،
يتحول حقًا إلى شيء يعمل بدوام كامل من
مشاركات سميث مقاطع مثل هذه ، إنه
مثال رائع على صنع  وضع سيء
أسوأ بالنسبة إلى حساب الأمان عبر الإنترنت الذي
أنشأه هو وآخرون ، لقد كان مشغولًا للغاية لدرجة أن
نظامنا عانى تحت العبء
كما حدث بالأمس على سبيل المثال ، كان هناك أكثر
من حادث تحطم واحد في الدقيقة في وقت مبكر من
بعد الظهر تم استدعاؤه إلى
مركز دورية 911 التابع للدولة تقريبًا  900 حادث تحطم
منذ يوم الأربعاء تقول إن دورية ولاية مينيسوتا
ما يقرب من 900
شخص آخر قد أصيب حوالي 80 شخصًا في
جميع التحديات التي كنا نتوقعها.
لقد حدثت العاصفة حقًا ويقول MnDOT
أننا لم نخرج من المغنية التي
تهب وتنزلق الثلوج لإغلاق
الطريق السريع 90 في جنوب غرب مينيسوتا مرة
أخرى اليوم ، إنه أمر مشبوه للغاية هناك
ولا نريد إنشاء حالات طوارئ جديدة
مع الناس أه تعلمون أنهم يدورون  بعيدًا عن
الطريق أو لديه أي مشاكل
يقول سميث إن هدفه نشر الوعي
بما وما لا يجب فعله ، إنه
جدار خرساني يتم
دفعهم إليه نوعًا ما إذا خرجت ولا
تخرج من سيارتك ، إنه يأمل في
تجميعات تحطم مثل هذه  لن
تجذب انتباهك فحسب ، بل تؤثر على
نواياك خلف عجلة القيادة في فلوريدا ، حيث توجد
أعاصير في كاليفورنيا حرائق غابات ،
وإذا أتيت إلى مينيسوتا ، فعلينا فقط
أن نتعلم كيف ندرك أن الطرق الملساء هي
شيء نتعامل معه